Hello friends I'm Jill morricone and we
just welcome you to another 3B and today
Bible Q and A that's right this is your
time to get your questions answered from
the word of God Hebrews 4 12 tells us as
the word of God is quick and Powerful
it's living it's alive and Powerful it
is sharper than any two-edged sword and
it pierces it brings conviction by the
anointing power of the Holy Spirit I
love this program because we get to
answer your questions we have our family
around the table here we're going to
introduce to you and it's my privilege
to introduce my dad well I call him dad
but this is actually Greg's father so
he's my father-in-law Pastor Daniel
morricone but you're like a dad to me
well thank you and you're like a
daughter to me yay what a blessing thank
you for having me on the program today
delighted to have you here and you help
out in our pastoral Department yes I'm
having a blast doing that that's
wonderful answering the phone people
have problems or whatever we get to pray
with people yeah blessing that's
wonderful so sitting next to Pastor
Daniel morricone is Daniel Perrin thank
you so much for being here Daniel yes
the second Daniel it's a good name and
uh you know just studying the Bible this
morning I had a bunch of questions and
they invite me back to say to the one
who has the answers there's lots of
questions and I love studying these amen
I love this program because we get to
dive deep into the word of God and study
and there's so much to learn the more I
study it seems like the more I don't
know and the more there is to learn
Pastor John lomachane at the end of the
table so glad you're here Pastor John
you know the Bible reminds us that we
are not able to comprehend the breath
and depth and height and length of God's
knowledge it always dwarfs us when we
walk into this room and recognize there
are no walls there are no floors there's
no ceiling that's what the study of
God's word does it reminds us that he's
sovereign and we're not so I'm always
learning as Daniel said when we step
into that room of unlimited Divine
knowledge amen men so we invite you to
learn along with us today we're going to
go to the Lord in prayer before we start
our first question but before we do that
we want to give you the way that you can
send in your questions we will answer
them on an upcoming Bible q a program so
first you can email us that's Bible QA
at
3abn.tv that email address again is
Bible QA at 3abn.tv or you can pick up
your cell phone and text us your
questions at
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 or you can go to Instagram
we get questions in Via Instagram and
the Instagram handle is 3abn underscore
official so that's 3bn's Instagram
handle and 3abn underscore official and
we want to answer your questions on an
upcoming Bible q a program before we go
any further we're go to the Lord in
prayer and Daniel would you pray for us
dear heavenly father Lord I Thank you
that you lead us through the word of God
step by step Page by Page verse by verse
and word by word you are there all the
way Lord as we study and listen and pray
and think today guide us as we want to
understand your word because we want a
clearer picture of Jesus in his name we
pray amen amen now we're going to get
into the word of God we're going to go
to Pastor John Lo McCain first and this
one I'm not sure who it comes from it
says well we all have to stand before
God and give an account for our sins
whether it be good or bad okay so you
might be startled to hear me say no
and here's the reason why let's read
second Corinthians 5 and verse 10 and
you might think what the Bible says so
listen to this carefully for we must all
appear before the judgments heat of
Christ that each one may receive the
things done in the body according to
what he has done whether good or bad let
me unfold it when we give our lives to
Christ he does not just become Our
Redeemer he becomes our Advocate first
John 2 verse 1 my little children these
things are right to you
so that you may not sin and if anyone
sins we have an advocate with the father
Jesus Christ the righteous so the
question is what does an advocate do
Hebrews 9 verse 24 for Christ has not
entered the holy place is made with
hands which are copies of the true but
into heaven itself listen carefully now
to appear in the presence of God for us
so he appears for us he's our he said if
you sin I'm your Advocate and what does
an advocate do he appears for us I've
heard people say well I don't have to go
to court my lawyer is going to represent
me that's what Jesus does in the
Judgment he represents us but here's the
other question
or here's the other point only those
whose sins are not atoned for will have
to give an account for those the
righteous will not have to appear for
the following reason their sins have
been atoned for the Apostle Paul I mean
the Apostle Peter preaching on the day
of Pentecost records these words in the
book of Acts Acts 3 19
he says repent therefore and be
converted that your sins may be blotted
out right so that times of refreshing
may come from the presence of the Lord
how can you why would you be called to
give an account of something that just
been blotted out you'll reckon has been
expunged
because our Advocate appearing before
the father for us atoning for us the
Lamb of God that taketh away the
sin of the world he took it away he's
our advocate so why do we have to appear
when our sins are blotted out somebody
may say your honor can you show me the
record of Daniel parent's sin he'll say
uh well uh
what uh sorry you're on a
we may be falsely accused him because
his record is clear that's what the Lord
does blots out our sins and he confirms
that Micah 7 verse 19
he will again have compassion on us
and we'll subdue our iniquities you will
cast all our sins into the depths of the
sea and put out a no fishing sign always
have to say that not only that Hebrews 8
and verse 12 for I will have mercy to
there I will be merciful to the
unrighteous and their sins and their
Lawless Deeds I will remember no more so
I I don't remember why Daniel's in court
I forgot why why he's here and I don't
see anything on the record why because
I've thrown his sins and you're
dismissed sir we can't accuse you of
anything that's why the beautiful story
of Joshua being accused by Satan the
Lord said you're just upset because he's
a brand plucked from the fire and that's
the beauty of all of us Proverbs 28 and
verse 13 says
he who covers his sins will not Prosper
but whoever confesses and forsakes them
will have mercy so that's what happened
when you go to the court and you are
innocent you ask for justice when you're
guilty you ask for Mercy we have mercy
because our father first John 4 verse 7.
so what happens when we stand in that
day of judgment love has been perfected
Among Us in this that we may have
boldness in the day of judgment because
as he is so are we in this world we have
boldness because Jesus Christ Our
advocate
our lamb our judge has blotted out our
sins the record is clear they are thrown
into the depths of the sea we have now
mercy and we could stand before the
father without any fear of being
condemned
Lehman thank you so much Pastor John I
wasn't sure where you were going with
the first no but I love that only the
wicked have to stand in judgment but the
righteous or clearing and that's the
great white thrown judgment in
Revelation 20. the books are open they
have to give an account that's powerful
let's go to Daniel Perron next this is a
text that came in when Malachi 4 speaks
that Elijah the prophet must first come
before that great and Dreadful day of
the Lord can you explain exactly what
that means okay the end of Malachi is
also the end of the prophets the nevaim
and the end of the prophets is looking
forward then to a new Prophet to another
Prophet so here's what we read at the
end of Malachi verse 5 and 6 of chapter
four behold I will send you Elijah the
prophet before the coming of the great
and Dreadful day of the Lord and He will
turn the hearts of the fathers to the
children and the hearts of the children
to their fathers lest I come and strike
the Earth with a curse so what's the day
of the Lord and will Elijah really
return in person the day of salvation is
the time we have right now this is when
time is open for decision making for for
God but the day of the Lord is when God
steps in and intervenes nationally for
Israel this is when is Israel's apostasy
was over and it was to be dealt with by
God but prophetically this looks forward
to a final worldwide ultimate day of the
Lord when divinely God steps in and
enter beings with sin but who is Elijah
coming well Elijah could not be
recognized by photos or physical
descriptions they didn't have those
things if they're going to recognize
Elijah coming it would be through his
prophetic message of restoration and
renewal that was intended to prepare the
way for God's divine intervention and in
Jesus day we learned this in Luke 9 18
to 20 people anticipated Elijah really
would come back in the flesh in person
people thought maybe Jesus Was Elijah
preparing the way but Jesus tells us
plainly that this refers to John the
Baptist ministry listen to Matthew 17
10-13 Jesus disciples asked him about
Elijah and Jesus says I say to you
Elijah has come already they did not
know him but they did whatever they
wished likewise the son of man is about
to suffer at their hands then the
disciples understood that he spoke to
them of John the Baptist and so the
angel Gabriel he also predicted this
when he when he came and told Zacharias
about the birth of John the the Baptist
Zacharias was John's father Luke 1 17
says that he will also go before him in
the spirit and power of Elijah to turn
the hearts of the fathers to the
children and the disobedient to the
wisdom of the just to make ready a
people prepared for the Lord so John the
Baptist his ministry there was to
prepare people for the day of the Lord
when God intervenes sending an
intervention to deal with sin but there
still is coming a final great day of the
Lord when there will be an intervention
from God that is final and complete and
so we should be looking for anticipating
the message of Elijah and what is that
first Kings 18 to 21 18 verse 21 says
how long will you falter between two
opinions if the Lord is God follow him
today is decision-making time but then
he repairs the altar focusing our
attention on the sacrifice and the
sanctuary and he turns the hearts of
parents to children and children to
parents God wants families United loved
to be healed families to be Ministry
tools pointing people to Jesus amen
thank you so much Daniel we talked about
end time judgment end time day of the
Lord we're going to stay kind of end
time New World we're going to go to Dad
here this question came from David who
sent it in via text from Florida well
the Heavenly Sanctuary remains standing
after the new world is created
wow that's a great question there David
thank you so much it helped me to dig in
the Bible also to figure this out and it
sounds like you're right there let's
quote this from the Bible here so that
our viewers wouldn't know what you're
talking about their Revelation 21 22.
the Bible says and I saw no Temple
therein for the Lord God Almighty
and the lamb are the Temple of it
and the word Temple actually comes from
a primary word meaning to dwell
and remember God telling Moses let them
make me a sanctuary that I may dwell
among them you know God loves to dwell
with his people that when Adam first
sinned that was the main thing you know
he was asking Adam where are you because
the every evening they would come and
talk and commune with each other they
would dwell together their hangout we
could say well Moses said let them make
me a sanctuary that I may dwell among
them you know possibly we've been
thinking of the sanctuary in um in a
small too small of an idea where God's
presence is where he's dwelling and
that's the sanctuary God's presence in
Psalm 102 verse 19 it says for he hath
looked down from the height of his
sanctuary
from Heaven did the Lord behold the
Earth that was Psalm 102 verse 19.
and then in Hebrews chapter 9 and verse
11 it says but Christ being come and
high priest of good things to come by a
greater and more perfect Tabernacle not
made with hands that is to say not of
this building and then jumping down to
verse 23 in Hebrews 9 it was necessary
that the patterns of things in the
heavens so this Earthly Sanctuary down
here was a pattern of the Heavenly
should be purified with these but the
Heavenly things themselves with better
sacrifices than these
for Christ is not entered into the holy
place it's made with hands which are the
figures of the true but into heaven
itself now to appear in the presence of
God for us and you recall Jesus's death
on the cross took care of all the
sanctuary type things the words were
killing the lamb and all of that so that
was no more necessary for that to be so
in that context the sanctuary as we knew
it on this Earth and in heaven is not
needed anymore so thank you again David
for that question and thank you for
listening
thank you so much Dad amen let's go to
something more practical now I love the
questions that you all send in some are
deeply theological and some are just
practical this is a practical question
we're going to Daniel Perrin this came
in Via Instagram what is the biblical
view of drinking coffee now this is a
loaded question all right well in
Genesis chapter 2 verse 1 God provided a
hydration source which was a river of
pure water water is absolutely essential
for every organ system and function of
the body and there is no substitute for
water when it comes to hydration and
cleansing and detoxifying lubricating
temperature regulation tissue
strengthening and much more so the
biblical view of drinking coffee is
drink water
coffee's popular though 2.25 billion
cups of coffee consumed in the United
States a worldwide daily 74 percent of
Americans drink coffee every day it is
the second most traded commodity only
after crude oil the average American
drinks 88.8 gallons of coffee a year
which is more than the average water
drinking in the United States it's just
a bean with water right so what does
coffee or any caffeine caffeinated drink
or food do when we consume it Job
chapter 10 verse 8 says your hands have
made and fashioned me an intricate unity
in other words whatever I consume
affects all of me physically and
spiritually so from the intestines
caffeine enters the bloodstream crosses
the blood-brain barrier where it blocks
the adenosine A1 receptors which give us
that tired feeling when we need rest so
that caffeine blood blocks those
receptors hijacks God's warning system
that prompts us to manage our labor and
rest cycles and by doing this we alter
God's order in the brain in that surplus
of adenosine then prompts the release of
adrenaline another stimulant and the
blocking of the a2a receptor releases
dopamine another stimulant and mood
enhancer but this receptor it it gets
desensitized over time so that caffeine
fails to produce the same feeling
meanwhile the caffeine restricts the
blood flow in the brain by up to 30
percent particularly to the frontal lobe
of our brain this is our reasoning
Center where we choose between right and
wrong where we hear and respond to the
voice of the Holy Spirit where we accept
and Obey God's law where we resist
temptation so weakened by the effects of
sin we need spiritual and moral strength
and caffeine instead of providing
spiritual and moral strength it weakens
that very every part of the brain where
we do that spiritual work with God that
is so essential
add to that a list of reported symptoms
related to caffeine consumption
irritability depressed mood nervousness
upset stomach muscle twitches insomnia
hormone imbalance poor sleep regulation
all of these don't appear to be what God
desires for us now I've heard claims
that caffeine or coffee has healthy
antioxidants God is so good he's given
us blueberries and pomegranates and
green leafy vegetables and fruits packed
and loaded with these wonderful things
without side effects God has given us
all sorts of things to eat and ways to
eat them that increase our strength and
boost our energy but not everything that
grows out of the earth is for our
consumption we know this because there
are things that do that have side
effects and do stuff to our body we
certainly avoid poisons that damage us
immediately but caffeine is one of those
that in our spiritual life doesn't
damage us there listen to this text here
in First Corinthians 10 31 there
therefore whether you eat or drink or
whatever you do do it all to the glory
of God and so God is inviting each one
of us to say take my gifts that I've
given to you to freely use that are
healthy for you and use those things and
it's by the holy spirit's power each one
of us have habits or things that we've
inherited from the past that God is
leading us to lay aside but drink pure
water it's good and it's good for you
friends thank you so much Daniel good
practical scientific too I like the
science backing before we go to the next
question I just want to remind you you
can send in your questions for an
upcoming Bible q a program where we'll
feature and answer your questions from
the word of God you can email us your
questions at bibleqa at
3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv or
you can text in your questions at
618-228-3975-618-228-3975 or you can
send in your questions via Instagram the
Instagram handle is 3abn underscore
official that's 3abn underscore official
we're going to go to Pastor John next
and this is still kind of a practical
question
this came from Daniel in but not the
Daniels on the set here Daniel in New
Zealand and he sent it in via email
can 777 be used in things like email
addresses bank card PIN numbers my
grandma says 777 is only for the cross
and should never be used on worldly
things can you shed some light on this
matter please
okay I could answer that question in one
second you can use 777 yes but let me
just tell you why some people have uh
the views that they do in reference to
the number seven at all you'll find in
the Bible if you go to Genesis chapter 5
and verse 31 the only place that 777 is
used in the Bible
is in describing the age of lamech the
Bible says altogether lamack lived a
total of
777 years and then he died so outside of
that you find a number of sevens and I
I'm a prophecy student I like the
scriptures and I I'm a numerologist if I
could use that phrase Loosely not in the
professional sense but I like to look at
the connections in scripture but these
numbers that come here's an association
that might even um spark your interest
to look deeply into it but suffice it to
say the number seven is not prohibited
the Bible doesn't prohibit the use of it
as a matter of fact what Daniel just
pointed out prohibition is prohibit the
things that affect your worship affect
your body affect your relationship with
God
the number seven is not one of those
here are some of the sevens in the Bible
you also find According to some Orthodox
beliefs the number seven is associated
with the representation of the threefold
Trinity 777 Father Son and Holy Spirit
so there you have that Association but
consider this
here's how the number seven finds itself
in scripture how many days in a week
seven
what day did God bless the seventh one
the seventh day of creation is called
the Sabbath Jesus and the apostles
observe the seventh day of the week
seventh day is a sign of allegiance to
our god Ezekiel 20 verse 12 and 20.
seven please priest blowing seven
trumpets and you find that just before
the fall of the wall of Jericho then
Revelation has a host of sevens and here
they are
seven churches seven spirits of God
Seven blessings most people don't see
that you have to look for that seven
golden lampstands Seven Stars which are
the seven angels to the seven churches
Seven Seals the Lamb with seven eyes and
seven horns seven angels that stand
before God and they are going to blow
the seven trumpets
seven Thunders seven thousand killed in
the earthquake just before the seventh
trumpet is sounded the Beast with seven
heads seven angel with seven vials with
the seven last plagues the Beast with
seven heads associated with the seven
mountains and seven kings that give
their power and support to the eighth
King from the bottomless pit but he has
a positive way to remember seven Matthew
18 verse 21 then Peter came to him that
is to Christ and said
Lord how often shall my brother sin
against me and I forgive him up to seven
times and Jesus in verse 22 said I do
not say to you up to seven times but up
to 70 times seven that's a positive way
of representing and knowing the beauty
of the number seven amen I love that
one is a
it could be a sensitive question but
it's a very important question it came
in via text is it a sin to indulge in
sex before marriage
wow that's a
good question thank you for sending that
in and I'm sure there's a lot of viewers
that would ask that question
and uh well my simple answer would be
yes it is a sin
to do sex before marriage but then you
were going to ask well why well because
God said so and then again that's not a
real good reason either I'm sure as far
as for most people so here's First John
3 4 just to show what sin is it says for
whosoever commit a sin transgresses also
the law for sin is the transgression of
the law
so then is adultery part of the law one
of the Ten Commandments
of the or the law of God it says Thou
shalt not commit adultery and then you
say well is uh having sex before
marriage adultery you know if you look
it up in the dictionary today it's more
it has to be a person that's married and
having sex or
with relations with someone that's not
their spouse
but if we go to Matthew Chapter 5 and
verse 27 here's Jesus's definition
I'm adultery he says ye have heard that
it was said by them of old time
Thou shalt not commit adultery
but I say unto you that whosoever
looketh on a woman to lust after her
hath committed adultery already in his
heart
so sex in any form
before marriage is sin but I don't want
to look at this from a deprivation angle
you know depriving of something that's
really great or good
um let's look at it from a positive
perspective that's good who created
mankind
who gave them sexual desires
and who would know best how to fulfill
them
there are a lot of powerful hormones
released in the sexual experience then
God put them there for man's pleasure
and bonding
the Bible says that they become one
flesh
and science tells us that the first
person that you have intercourse with
actually physiologically Alters the
brain causing an imprint forever
you know I heard this example many years
ago imagine it's 30 degrees below zero
and uh you know you've seen those
faucets that work even though it's cold
outside it's metal
so you go outside and you put your
tongue
on this metal water pipe and you leave
it there for about a minute by the way
don't do this at home
then remove it you're going to leave
part of your tongue on the pipe and
that's what happens when you have sexual
relations you become one flesh and when
you break apart you leave Part of
Yourself emotionally
and you might be saying well I'll never
we'll never break up well that's
wonderful and I pray that you never do
but let's look at the positives for
waiting till after marriage
what is more valued something that comes
easy or something that you have to work
for or wait for
you know God's formula was for man and
woman to bond first and then have
intercourse intimacy is something that
has long-term satisfaction and brings
contentment
in Genesis 4 1 and Adam knew Eve his
wife and she conceived and bear Cain so
this knowing or intimacy precedes
intercourse SO waiting till after
marriage will bring you both the
greatest satisfaction you'll have
greater trust for each other
you won't be bringing guilt into the
relationship we already have our own
baggage that we bring in dealing with
why add any more and I wish God's
blessing upon you whoever you are and
God's plan is always the best formula to
follow and if you've already started you
can actually put it on pause build the
trust get married and then push resume
and lastly remember God gave it to us
for intimacy and I like to say that into
me see
opening up oneself no walls perfect
trust and openness that brings
satisfaction that you're really Desiring
otherwise you're just using it as a drug
which is just distracting you from this
fulfillment that God has for you I'm
asking the question amen thank you so
much Dad I'm not I don't think I'm going
to forget that illustration but it's a
powerful one that's really good
praise the Lord that there is
forgiveness if you have stepped into
that and that God can redeem and God can
enable us to walk in that Victory let's
go to Pastor John this came from Nancy
who lives in New York she sent in a text
was Satan raining down fire on job
another very quick answer yes you know
God job is a beautiful example of one
who had endurance and endurance is
something that so many of us don't have
you know our job
doesn't treat us right we quit uh the
car broke down we're not going to go
back to work again and we something
happens at church we stop going to
church job is the perfect example in
scripture of a person with endurance the
lord gave the enemy Satan access to job
you find job 1 verse 8 to 12 because
Satan was convinced that he's only
serving you because you're protecting
him listen to what the Bible says
and the Lord said no that's not the case
his heart is right with me so Job 1
verse 8 to 12 then the Lord said to
Satan have you considered my servant job
that there is none like him on the earth
the blameless and upright man
one who fears God and shuns evil
so Satan answered the Lord and said
does job fear God for nothing have you
made a hedge about him around his
household and around all that he has on
every side you have blessed the work of
his hands and his possessions have
increased in the land
but now
stretch out your hand and touch him on
and all that he has and he will surely
curse you to your face
and the Lord said to Satan behold all
that he has is in your power only do not
lay a hand on his person so Satan went
out from the presence of the Lord so God
gave Satan access and I praise God for
that because the devil can't do to us
what God does not allow him to do you
know he said to Peter the devil desires
to have you that he may sift you as we
but I pray that your faith will not fail
if the devil could do his own bidding
without God prohibiting him he would
wipe us out even now God put a hedge
between the devil and said you can go
this far but no farther and the Bible
says in Job 1 verse 16
a reporter came back one of the Servants
of job while I was speaking
another also came and said the fire of
God fell from heaven and burned up the
sheep and the servants and consumed them
and I alone have escaped to tell you now
you read that and you say well the Bible
says the fire of God no just like
tornadoes today God was accused of the
fire we call it even the act of God
insurance companies say well that's an
act of God we are not going to cover
that no the devil not only sent the fire
but tried to blame God for the
conflagration and was not God and so in
the very end you'll find when you read
the Bible in Revelation 13 the devil
once again is going to bring down fire
from heaven on Earth in the sight of man
to deceive those who dwell on the Earth
by the means of those miracles
which he had power to do in the sight of
the Beast but still once again why would
he use fire he remembered that God
answered Elijah by fire he remembered
that fire was a symbol on the day of
Pentecost of the power of God he knows
that fire is a symbol of God anointing
our lives and consuming sin and he uses
it for the purpose of deception so yes
he was the one that brought the fire
down thank you so much Pastor John we're
going to go to Daniel Perrin next this
came in from Ruthie who lives in
Tennessee and it's a text
since the mark of the beast and the mark
of God are not physically visible how
will store owners know who to sell to
and who not to sell to
all right this is a practical question
too we're looking to the Future and
seeing how does God's prophecies get
fulfilled I want to read Revelation 13
verses 16 and 17 says that he causes all
both small and great rich and poor free
and slave to receive a mark on their
right hand or on their foreheads and
that no one may buy or sell except one
who has the mark and so many people ask
how could this prophetic picture of the
United States with modern worldwide
influence possibly come true it doesn't
seem possible that the United States
seen as a defender of Freedom would so
blatantly abolish freedoms and that
people would participate with it so I
want you to notice three things number
one this isn't just a physical or
political conflict it is a spiritual
conflict and a final Conflict there will
be spiritual forces working through
people to wage all-out war seen and
unseen and Satan will go go to any links
to carry out his Wicked purposes of
Destruction so we should not say that
couldn't happen
and number two I want you to notice that
it is the beast's power this is the
political nation that prevents those
from having the mark from buying or
selling now the government which
represents the will of the people will
seek to convert or eradicate one group
of people because they will not worship
a harmless looking alternative to the
beast called the image of the beast in
other words conditions in the world will
be so will be such that it will convince
the majority that it is for the common
good to eliminate a minority who are
clearly on the wrong side of a most
urgent issue so urgent that it is enough
to Forfeit our constitutional freedoms
it will not be life as usual desperate
times will call for desperate measures
and today's news reveals a steady tread
of events for those who are looking
governments are already using Financial
restriction and economic isolation to
put pressure on people in a recent
article I read reported that at 93
percent of world banks are at some level
working on a central bank digital
currency where all Financial
transactions can be managed or
supervised by a government agency now
without conjecturing too much about the
future I want to recognize that a tool
of this significance and magnitudes can
certainly be put into effect to restrict
the financial autonomy of somebody who
is deemed an enemy of the people
number three I want you to notice that
this text tells us that the world will
be divided into only two groups and the
contrast between them will be Stark and
obvious there will be no confusion as to
which group somebody is a part of on the
one hand one group is filled with the
Holy Spirit radiating from their life
seen as their willingness to die for
loyal allegiance to God Express through
worship and the other group by contrast
is devoid of the Holy Spirit completely
motivated by self willing to kill for
the same issue of worship which they
believe is obedience to God as well now
we don't need to know exactly how
prophecy will be fulfilled but we can
trust that God who has fulfilled every
prophecy up to now will carry out
exactly and we will see exactly what God
has predicted amen thank you so much
Daniel so important that we make a
choice today for Jesus and to be on the
right side and then to evangelize and
share the gospel with others so they
have that opportunity to make a choice
as well let's go to Dad this is another
text we got a lot of text on this
program here this came from Linda in
California
why does the bible use Holy Spirit in
some places and Holy Ghost in other
places
and that was Linda Linda thank you Linda
for sending that question
and that is a good question why does it
do one you know sometimes Holy Ghost and
sometimes Holy Spirit
know the English terms Holy Ghost and
holy spirit they're completely
synonymous with each other actually one
derives from the old English word ghast
and when you look that up in the
Merriam-Webster Dictionary it says that
it was an obsolete word it means to
scare and it gives a little example from
Shakespeare's writings
and here here goes quote gasted by the
noise that I made
full suddenly he fled
that's old English
and the other four from the Latin loan
word it's a that's a word that was
adopted from a foreign language with
little or no modification and that's
spiritus
so like pneuma they both refer to breath
to its animating power and the soul and
then I looked it up
in on the internet here with uh
Don Stewart from Blue Letter bible.org
to give him credit
it says why the difference in
translations the reason for the
difference is found in the story behind
the translation of the King James Bible
when the New Testament was translated
from Greek into English it was done by
different committees
and one of the Committees consistently
translated the Greek word
hagian pneuma as Holy Spirit
while the other committee translated it
as Holy Ghost so when the translation
was completed and these differences just
remained in the text there
so thus you have the spirit of God
referred to as both the Holy Spirit and
the Holy Ghost yet there's no
distinction between the two
that's your answer
I love that
it's so fascinating to study the word to
get in and to learn that and to see that
we're going back to Daniel Perrin here
this is what I don't know who it's from
it says what does Isaiah 8 verses 11
through 22 mean
all right I can't read all of those
verses here and still answer the
question so you should go and read the
whole chapter the current events of
Isaiah 8 are these king ahaz of Judah is
facing a powerful United enemy King
resin of Syria and King Pekka of Israel
Allied against him there's two ways to
view current events one of them is to
trust in God's promises and act
accordingly the other way is to trust in
human wisdom and strength making
alliances with the world's methods
instead so God's promise in Isaiah 8 is
made plain through Isaiah in chapter 7
chapter 7 verse 14 and onward and
particularly the first four verses of
Chapter eight the promise is this while
Isaiah's child Maher shalal hashbaz is
still a child the two kings that ahaz is
facing will be defeated by Assyria there
is no need for you to go and seek help
from any other human Nation Isaiah
writes this down in a prophecy in verse
3 it is testified by two witnesses it's
a testify this is God's prophetic word
and this is why Isaiah says in verse 6
verse 18 here am I and the children whom
the Lord has given me we are for signs
and wonders in Israel even his family
and our family should be too is a Living
Testament of trusting in God's prophetic
word all right now on the other hand
verses 11 and 12 of chapter 8 tell us
that the people they want a Confederacy
or a conspiracy or an alliance we want
help from some other nation and they're
seeking help from others instead of God
they don't trust God verse 19 tells us
that this Confederacy really is seeking
alliance with demons listen to this when
they say to you seek those who are
mediums and wizard Wizards who whisper
and mutter should not a people seek
their God so verse 21 and 22 says that
if you read those texts when we look for
Success outside of God we're not going
to find it it'll be as if we're walking
in darkness we will reap the bitter
curses of our decision and then we will
blame other people for it and so the
solution verse 16 is this bind up the
testimony and seal the law among my
disciples and we see it again in verse
20. to the law and to the testimony if
they do not speak according to this word
there is because there is no light in
them the testimony remember is God's
prophetic word when we are facing
current events where we see trouble on
the horizon hold tight to God's
prophetic word God's prophecies will not
fail and we will face United enemies
against God's people God's prophetic
word will not fail to the testimony but
then to the law the word there is Torah
and this is God's teaching throughout
the Bible it's his moral law as well as
all of God's teaching and this lets us
know this is not just about the the
events that took place in Isaiah 8 this
is for all people of all places God's
law is what we should turn our attention
to Isaiah now is strengthened listen to
verse 11 it says for the Lord spoke to
me with a strong hand God strengthened
me and instructed me I should not walk
in the ways of the people trust in God's
prophetic word trust in the Bible amen
wonderful encouragement we're going to
come back to Dad here and this is
another kind of Bible translation
question this came in via text
why is Matthew 17 21 left out of some
Bible translations another good question
there and doesn't have the author of
that question but
the more modern translations they don't
include it because they had we found
better manuscripts to get the
translation from just to go back in
history how these translations came
about
like the King James version in is
translated or completed its translation
in 1611 came from the Texas receptus
which was a Greek
rendition of the New Testament but it
was revised you know Erasmus with a guy
that wrote that and he revised it
several times
but the New Testament in the King James
was about 84 percent
from translated from a guy named Tyndale
he was the original guy translating it
into English and the King anyway he
needed a quick translation to make
himself look good
so the English but it doesn't change the
meaning when you look at this text here
and you know a scribe probably added it
by mistake because when they looked at
the older
um
manuscripts it wasn't in the older
manuscripts
and so but it most of them think that it
was from Mark chapter 9 verse 29 Mark 9
29 it says let me just turn here 9 29
says and he said unto them this kind
come forth by nothing but by prayer and
fasting so when the translators didn't
have it in when they were translating
Matthew They just added that in there
um but if you look in Bible we're
supposed to compare scripture with
scripture so there's three all these uh
gospel writers the three synoptic ones
wrote this story in Luke chapter nine
and going to verse 37
has this same story
without this fasting in prayer
and it came to pass that on the next day
when they were come down from the hill
much people met him and behold a man of
the company cried out saying master I
beseech thee look upon my son for he's
mine my only child and Lois Spirit
taketh him and he suddenly crieth out
and it teareth him and he fulleth again
and bruising him hardly departed from
him and I besought thy disciples to cast
him out and they could not and Jesus
answering said o faithless and perverse
generation how long shall I be with you
and suffer you bring thy son hither and
as he was yet coming the devil threw him
down and tear him and Jesus rebuked the
unclean spirit and healed the child and
delivered him again to his father so he
doesn't even mention what Mark and then
they added to Matthew there it doesn't
really change the thought of the text
and in second Peter chapter 1 21 it
we're told how inspiration is given
second Peter
chapter
1 verse 21. it says that holy men of God
spake or we could add wrote as they were
moved by the holy spirit so we believe
in thought inspiration rather than word
inspiration God's word is true you can
depend on it amen thank you so much Dad
last question here is for Pastor John
this is from Norma who lives in Florida
and she sent it in via text in reference
to Revelation 2 verse 17. well everyone
who goes to heaven get a white stone
I love this one huh you know this this
one is so synonymous to the mercy of God
I'll read the text Revelation 21
Revelation 2 verse 17. here it is
he who has an ear let him hear what the
spirit says to the churches to him who
overcomes I will give some of the Hidden
Manna to eat and I will give him a white
stone and on the stone a new name
written which no one knows except him
who receives it when I study this oh
easily about 25 years ago I was doing a
revelation seminar in California and I
thought white stone and I wanted to
wrote read through a number of books to
find out the history behind this and I
discovered in the Roman court system it
was set up pretty much like ours today
very judicially said a lot of what
happens in America you can find the
roots in the Bible
and when the accused when the jury could
not come to a verdict it was left up to
the accused to determine his own fate oh
wow and so what was a nervous moment
because they had a leather bag
and uh kind of like kind of like one of
those game shows you had to put your
hand in the bag and choose a white stone
or a black stone if you pick the black
stone that's it crucifixion
if you chose the white stone you're
exonerated now going back to what we
talked about earlier about Jesus being
our advocate notice he says I will give
you
a stone with a new name on it so he says
wait a minute Daniel I've been picking
on you today wait wait before you go
I'm going to give you this Stone
so you put your hand in the bag you
already have the white stone now they
don't know that
but I have exonerated you already I have
represented you I've atoned for your
transgression so when he took the stone
out
it says I will give him a stone a white
stone the beauty of that Jesus in his
Mercy
stands with us at the bar of accusation
and because we told our Advocate if if
we confess our sins he is faithful and
just to forgive us our sins cleanse us
from all unrighteousness first John 1 9.
so why they're waiting for us to condemn
ourselves
he says Hey because you've been open
with me I have atoned for your sin so if
you are if your sins are forgiven and
you are cleansed from all
unrighteousness what Stones should you
have a white stone and then you are
exonerated your name is change for
anonymity you know the name Daniel is no
longer associated with a crime he gets a
new name but he looks like Daniel no
that's not Daniel and that's why the
Bible says in Daniel 7 verse 22 I love
these words
speaking about the court scene the white
stone is a symbol that the court will
always exonerate those covered by the
blood of the Lamb Daniel 7 22 until the
Ancient of Days came and judgment was
made in favor of the Saints and the time
came for the Saints to possess the
Kingdom so the white stone is the symbol
of God's exonerating justice and mercy
for those covered by the blood of the
Lamb he gives it to us we don't have to
earn it amen what a tremendous blessing
it's been an insightful study you all
are great students of the word I have
learned here today and we hope you've
learned as well we just have a couple
moments left and I'm going to throw out
a question
how do you all study the Bible I know
sometimes when we travel or people ask
us how do you study so is there devices
you use is there a certain method you
use we don't have much time we'll just
go around the circle okay I'll let
Daniel throw it in Chris
um I could talk forever regularity is
number one and I I just I move my way
through every book of the Bible not
always in an order but and then I start
back through and I do a lot of
underlining and highlighting trying to
connect words and phrases to places
where I find them in other parts of the
Bible so that way the whole Bible kind
of connects as a a unit and over years
it gets easier and easier I like that
and like he said that's my Bible there
this is the second time we're going
through my wife and I together and boy
we have some rich Bible studies we
associate hey I read that in the New
Testament we highlight so that's exactly
what we do when the word of God is in
your heart it begins to flow out of you
it becomes a living Fountain of water
and you don't have to guess then you can
claim its promises so regularity
consistency Thy word have I hit in my
heart and what a difference it makes
amen dad in a few seconds yeah well I do
it in the morning and I love to do
different translations each year I just
go through the Bible in a different
translation and it blesses me amen I
like that so these are all wonderful
tips regularity consistency try
different translations Mark your Bible
study with others I love that and
there's tremendous Bible apps I like
Bible Hub
um because you can look up the Greek and
the Hebrew and it pulls in the strongs
without having to look it up the
concordance and that's tremendous and it
has the other translations what we want
to do right now is give you an
opportunity to send in your questions
which we want to feature on an upcoming
Bible q a program it's so important to
open up the word it's important to study
and it's important to learn so here's
how you can contact us at 3bn and we
would love to answer your question on an
upcoming Bible q a program
if you're enjoying our 3abn Bible q a
then tell your friends each Monday will
bring you a fresh program answering the
Bible questions you send us using God's
holy word to shed light on those texts
that seem difficult to understand to
have your questions answered on a future
program just email them to us at bibleqa
at 3abn.tv that's Bible QA at 3abn.tv
you may also text your questions to
618-228-3975 that's
618-228-3975 be sure to include your
name and where you live and then
watch3abian Bible q a for answers from
God's word
welcome back we've had an amazing study
of the word of God today and we thank
you for joining us thank you all for
your contributions and for sharing and
why don't you all give a closing thought
we'll start with Dad well I want to
thank the viewers those that sent their
questions in because it really helped me
to study more and I learned stuff it was
real blessing for me as I studied to
find out these different things so thank
you so much
Daniel you know pure water is a symbol
of Jesus we see it in John 4 we see it
in John 7 and then in the very last
chapter of the bible let him who thirsts
come whoever desires let him take the
Water of Life freely that's right and I
always like to end with the mercy of God
you know we all are sinners Fallen
Fallen far from God but he says in
Ezekiel 33 14 and 16
when I say to the wicked you shall
surely die if he turns from his sin and
does what is lawful and right verse 16
none of his sins which he has committed
shall be remembered against him he has
done what is lawful and right and he
shall surely live who of us which of us
which of you listening have not needed
the mercy of God what's so wonderful God
is Not seeking ways to destroy us and to
get rid of us he's long-suffering
towards us not willing that any of us
should perish amen thank you so much
Pastor John and Daniel
and for being
here thank you for your study of the
word of God and for being part of the
family and we thank you for joining us
as well Pastor John referenced Ezekiel
it reminded me of this scripture I want
to leave you with we're in Ezekiel 18. I
think this is one of the saddest
scriptures in the word Ezekiel 18 31
cast away from you all the
transgressions which you have committed
and get yourselves a new heart and a new
spirit for why should you die oh House
of Israel if you have not made a
decision to make Jesus Christ the lord
of your life today is the day of
salvation ask him into your heart he
will forgive you and redeem you we'll
see you next time
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]